hey this is presh talwalkar
a circle with the radius equal to 1 is
divided into 12 congruent regions as
shown
what is the perimeter of a single region
i think chan lai lee
whose video explained the solution to
this problem
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
let's label the three lengths of a
single region
label the long arc as having a length
equal to a
the short arc as b and the straight line
segment as c
the circumference of a circle with the
radius equal to 1 is equal to 2 pi
but we also know the circumference of
the circle is equal to 6 a
therefore 6 a is equal to two pi which
means a is equal to two pi over six
now focus on the following arc
its length is equal to a but it's also
equal to b plus b therefore b is equal
to a over two
which is equal to pi over six
a plus b is then equal to three pi over
six which equals pi over two
the perimeter of a single region is
therefore equal to pi over 2 plus c
it remains to calculate the length c
now let's focus on the following
congruent regions and let's label some
of the points
notice that e h and g
are equidistant from the points f and o
so they all lie along the perpendicular
bisector of f o which means they are
collinear
construct the chord e h g
now
e h is equal to e g minus g h
furthermore
g gfho is a circular sector
so gf equals gh equals go
and all of these are equal to one
therefore gh is equal to one
let's now construct the following line
segments
we're going to construct two equilateral
triangles
we know they're equilateral triangles
because o f is equal to oe
and since we know the arc fe is equal to
two pi over six or pi over three
we have a central angle f o e that's
equal to pi over three or 60 degrees
therefore f o e is an isosceles triangle
with a vertex angle equal to 60 degrees
which means it's an equilateral triangle
the same goes for ofg
label the point k as the intersection of
fo with eg
we know that oe is equal to one
and e ek bisects the equilateral
triangle
so the shorter leg is equal to one-half
and the height or the longer leg is
equal to square root of three over two
this is true for both ek and gk
so we have that e h is equal to square
root of three over two plus square root
of three over two minus one which is
equal to the square root of three minus
one
therefore c is equal to the square root
of three minus one
this means the perimeter is equal to pi
over 2 plus the square root of 3 minus 1
and that's approximately equal to 2.303
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]
you